[Music]
the Muellers name is an acronym for
massive unidentified terrestrial
organism in one of the original
screenplays for Godzilla the Mutis were
called hawk Muto and femme Muto which
was short for Hokkaido Muto and female
Muto altogether there are four meters
that exist in the monster verse in a
2014 film the mirrors are referred to as
such but are also referred to
numerically with a male being designated
as muta 1 and female as muta to the
third meter is therefore presumably
known to monarch as muted free the
murals are an ancient parasitic
arthropod species that evolved during
the Permian period of Earth's history
technically the Muellers are a part of
the smallest subspecies of the much
larger muta prime like Godzilla they
feed off of the Earth's radiation let's
dive on to the four types of Mutis muta
one the male being the first member to
be encountered is described as a young
growing and looking for food before
meeting the female so he consumes a
radiation to gain strength this mural is
seen to be 200 feet tall and probably
weighed in the 10,000 ton range numerous
bodies are covered in an iridescent
metallic grayish black exoskeleton they
have orange red narrowly shaped eyes the
shape of the head is reminiscent of
gaius and they have triangular jaws
resembling a hooked beak with the male
Muto having two mana bells while the
female only has one the male Muto is
able to unleash electromagnetic pulses
from its claws which can disable
electric up artists in a five-mile wide
radius the male mural has wings which it
can use the flyer on the air at a stop
speeds is undetermined naturally these
wings aid him in seeking out radiation
to offer to the female the wings also
gave the male a massive combat advantage
against Godzilla he would usually be
able to escape back into the skies
before Godzilla could retaliate the male
spend most of his time after hatching
flying around in a constant hunt for
radiation and most importantly the
potential mate the male muta was strong
enough to drag Godzilla away from the
female muta without difficulty and
dredge up a Russian attack submarine
from the depths of the ocean and pull it
dozens of miles inland on the Island of
Hawaii Muto - the female once the male
have matured enough awake
adamancy in Traverse to Las Vegas and
other environments to meet with the male
she is seen as having eight limbs
although only six were used for walking
around the female muta was larger than
the main muta being around 300 feet tall
and weigh heavy and also bulk bulkier in
appearance she lacks the ability to fly
but is durable enough to withstand even
the atomic breath of the g-man despite
their resemblances to ultra cuts the
mirrors are of vertebrate biology the
female is twice as large as the male but
lacks the wings like five flies and
seven was the female Muto has the
ability to reproduce sexually she lays
hundreds of X near radioactive object so
that when the offsprings hatch they can
immediately feed off the radiation as
parasites the females of the mutabrid
the species lays their eggs inside the
radioactive carcasses of the large of
Godzilla species in order to reproduce
the Muto's have shown to be intelligent
enough to work as a team and the female
was also able to quickly determine false
involvement in the destroying of a nest
muta prime even bigger than the female
muta or maybe even bigger than godzilla
himself muta prime is portrayed as
another subspecies a more ancient one
that have battled an ancient ancestor of
Godzilla and actually won the fight
she might be almost all around 400 feet
tall the muta prime is nearly identical
in appearance to the regular female Muto
except for several notable differences
the muta prime has a hardened outer
shell with razor sharp back spires on it
large orange glowing volumes as well as
several smaller pairs of four limbs on
her chest
the muta Prime is classified as having
the behavior of a destroyer she also
appears to have some sort of rivalry
with Godzilla muta prime is only seen
attacking humans in order to obtain
sources of radiation and doesn't seem to
kill out of pure malice jinchen mushi is
an imposing specimen would raise his
sharp back spires towering atop a hot
and outer shell making it an unstoppable
mountain of a time as erupts from the
earth powerful legs strike the ground
like a devastating seismic salvo of
cannons heard for miles with each tundra
stub digging into the earth to take a
battle-hardened stance on the surface
against any tightened aggressor it faces
muta tree the second female muta is
among the tightest being monitored by
Mona and has awakened by Ghidorah skal
she is later seen in Boston after
Godzilla defeats Ghidorah and she boughs
down to Godzilla acknowledging him as a
new alpha this new muta of the very
similar to the female mutant in the 2014
film bears slight differences which
brings up a question whether she is a
juvenile form of the muta prime it
hasn't been stated as yet but it's
popular fan believe that this mirror is
a subspecies akin to the muta prime of
Godzilla after-show not much is known
about this Muto except for the fact that
she was in North America and attacked
cities and human settlements there she
was also quick enough to reach Boston at
the end anyway do tell us your thoughts
in the comment section and what videos
you want us to make like share subscribe
and all that fun stuff
[Music]